hey guys this is dance the founder think
Cara and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of M night Shyamalan after
earth starring will smith and jaden
smith or should i say really starring
Jaden Smith the father and son duo yeah
Will Smith con takes a backseat in this
movie which is unfortunate I have to say
I'm kind of disappointed because not
that it wasn't better that it wasn't
worse I was expecting a much worse not
not to say that it's not a good movie no
but it's not his worst movie sometime
much my mom's blood after you know
seeing the happening and the last
airbender which you could if you've seen
my review I just bashed that movie you
can i'll post a link below tunis or
something yeah the cod the animation is
great movie was terrible so I was
expecting kind of like a bomb on that
level yeah that's where disappointing me
where it just was a not good movie
versus a terrible terrible awful movie
right yeah it wasn't terrible it wasn't
the worst dialogue o Shah Mahalo written
yeah there wasn't much dialogue no I
almost had like kind of a he had a
co-writer the guy that rowboat book of
eli co-wrote it right but i feel i
didn't mind though yeah decent yells
decent movie but this uh because Will
Smith isn't in the center of attention
this movie because jayden is responsible
for leading the season he is definitely
not strong enough to be a leading male
you know actor like he's just he's not
his presence he has one look that he
uses the whole is how he looked at he
uses the whole movie and it's like he
just there's no rain she has no range
yeah my biggest complaint is that this
movie is so boring right cuz at least
you know I recently just watched lady in
the water for the first time it's
terrible right but at least with that
and happening in last airbender they're
so bad that like it's actually kind of
interesting to see how bad it is like
the dialogue and all that stuff um this
one just it's it kind of put me to sleep
yeah I mean there's just not much to the
story it's sooo it's real simple like I
was honey I think if this was an episode
like an hour-long episode of TV 45
minutes like about you know going to a
planet having a little adventure and
then going back home then maybe I could
have been like okay like it's just a
regular our television but as a big
budget over
a million dollar movie for over an hour
and 40 minutes I just didn't see the
point of it yeah if you've seen the
trailer you've pretty much seen the
movie I mean yeah the trailer explains
it all and and also I mean really the
plot of the movie is Jaden Smith trying
to get a cell phone reception for two
hours yeah basically he's just going
like hey where's the signal yeah yeah
but so like and then there's some action
sequences but they're just not there
they're just not that interesting
they're kind of stuff you've seen before
and I don't know even the environment
that that kind of maybe a part where is
actually really disappointing not the
like about how bad it is but I actually
was disappointed that I were being on
after earth I the the creatures or just
everything that environment didn't seem
too um I don't know just didn't seem too
futuristic or different or anything like
that I wanted to see some
post-apocalyptic earth I mean there's
like this is in a regular jungle yeah I
mean it could have been any planet they
landed on like there's nothing about it
that made it uniquely earth no Magus
maybe the animals I mean but that yeah
but that actually kind of made her
almost worse cuz they like it was just
monkeys and right things that we already
seen before and they helped it up as
every animal on this planet has evolved
to kill humans I'm like yeah they're
little bigger I guess it's like it's
like Planet of the Apes and me it's not
that big of a do I don't know just
didn't have any impact there's no
nothing unique about what we were seeing
on screen so and we were talking about
Jaden Smith in and like a lot of people
or kind of like down on this movie
because of the the nepotism of you know
Will Smith having it really is kind of a
bait-and-switch movie that kind of
advertises a Will Smith movie but really
it's Jaden Smith is the main character
will smith sits in a chair right for the
whole movie oh he's throughout it yeah
he's talking right but didn't do
anything sits in a chair he's trying to
promote his kid yes my beef with it's
like I understand that I mean if I had a
kid and I was Will Smith maybe I do the
same thing but like I respectable Smith
in the sense at least he earned his
bones like he worked his way from the
bottom all the way at the top doing his
own
thing Jaden hasn't done anything really
did the karate kid which I was an awful
adaptation sei i actually didn't mind
the chronic okay i didn't mind it hey
but at the same time it's like these are
vehicles that his father's put him in
yeah he didn't like he didn't get cast
running these roles they didn't go oh
man this guy is such a good actor or
something like that like okay we're
gonna cast him cuz were elements when I
was watching moving like maybe this
could have been good like it could have
been like a castaway kind of movie on a
strange planet like just forget the
earth knew something to like that like
castaway with Tom Hanks but i think it
was trying to be serious and deep ocean
oh and every time Jaden would like get
emotional and start crying this like
that same look on his face I didn't feel
anything honey feeling emotion no
neither did I and you take someone like
Will Smith who's a very charismatic
personality he he talked really slowly
and very robotic Lee yeah that was his
Ellison that was hos whole voice all
right time and so I don't know if that's
the direction or the writing or
something they just they took that out
of him cuz the story was by Will Smith
it was written you know the co-head with
shah mohan and the other guy but so I
yeah I don't know what what was trying
to go with this I don't know where he
was going or what he was trying to make
like I think if you don't make a fun
sci-fi action adventure than do that but
I don't know it just felt like I said
it's just trying to promote his son here
and that's what it felt like like here
here's my son here's Jaden like use him
he's got ya so yeah overall I just I
mean I'm gonna give it like a c-minus
d-plus it's not a it's not like an ass
like the happening last airbender those
are apps this is like Heidi low seas
yeah just my biggest complaint that it
was boring yeah it wasn't so much that
it was terrible I mean it's not a good
movie it's bad but it's just so boring
yeah I mean I would do the same thing I
think c-minus d-plus the movie it's
boring it's only like an hour and 40
minutes but you feel all of that hour
and 40 minutes unlike Avengers like two
and a half hours just flies by so I mean
I say maybe rent it when it comes out I
was just rented but yeah it's definitely
not the worst I'm my travel on it but
certainly that is that how far we've
come where I know it like sighs were
yeah like a c-minus d-plus movie is that
his were said he's almost like he's
playing it safe yeah he wasn't I think I
think so oh alright guys uh before you
go I won't let guys know that we are
moving youtube channels we were moving
to a think hero pro I'm going to post
the link right here yeah this is our new
channel that's where our reviews are
going to be we're gonna have like other
news opinion videos interviews and some
narrative and sketch stuff also you can
check us out on twitter minds at think
kara i'm at griffin de and we a saw the
facebook page that's a facebook.com
slash think hero fans